all right I hope you all had a great a
great weekend my weekend was was pretty
good though I did make a mistake that I
feel like I should tell you about kind
of a cautionary tale I told my kids the
twins who are kindergarten age that they
could watch the movie King Kong over the
weekend the one not the really old ones
but the one from 2005 directed by Peter
Jackson and I saw when it first came out
but that was like 15 years ago almost so
it been a long time my memory of the
movie is that it was kind of a family
adventure family-friendly nice little
safe flick that kids of all ages could
enjoy that's my memory of it when I saw
him 15 years ago so the point is that i
vouched for it with my wife I told my
kids I can watch King Kong they were
super excited and then my wife was was
said I don't know about that is that
appropriate it's fine don't worry about
it I saw it no big no big deal it's fine
I guess it been so long that I forgot
how scary and violent it is in certain
parts and much more than I remembered
and it looked like the kids were being
slightly traumatized by some of the
scenes I was so I was fast I was
johnny-on-the-spot with the fast-forward
button making sure to get through the
scarier parts so that they were still
watching them but just fat but just
faster look I figured that's not as bad
anyway III fast ported most of the bad
parts except I forgot about a part
because it happens very quickly towards
the end where King Kong bites off a
guy's head almost like an old-fashioned
grenade he bites off the head spits the
head out throws the body
I forgot that that happen I just didn't
he didn't register me at the time and I
didn't I wasn't able to fast forward and
the the real problem though was that my
wife who had not been watching the movie
at all this entire time with us she
happens to walk in right before that
happens and sits down and says well
watch it with you and then the head
biting thing happens my my son of course
loves it he DS these are they he did
King Kong just bit off a guy's head did
you see that Mommy and I'm sitting there
like kid just stop yes don't don't don't
and my wife gives me that look you know
it's a very specific
look that your wife gives you it's a
very specific you let the kids watch
something inappropriate look and so I'm
getting that look not a good look but
what I what I tried to argue is that
kids have to be exposed to this reality
at some point right the fact that
gorillas bite people's heads off that's
that's something that would you rather
they look they learn it on the streets
is that what you want you want them to
go out there and learn it the hard way
that a good that that 40-foot gorillas
we could bite your head off no this is
something that they need to learn in a
safe environment at home so that we
could teach them that yes this is
sometimes gorillas bite people's heads
off important life lesson so if you see
a 40-foot gorilla just avoid him you
know or wear a helmet I guess I wouldn
tell much if your head is detached from
your body anyway okay before we go any
further we need to talk briefly about
Duke cannon you know using soap every
day is a good idea it makes you I think
a well kempt person your loved ones your
friends and people around you will thank
you for it practicing good hygiene but
you know it also makes you a patriot
especially if you're using Duke Canon
consider this Duke canons superior
quality grooming goods for hard-working
men are tested by soldiers Duke cannon
partners with active duty military to
develop new ideas and review products
anything that doesn't meet the high
standards of our military just goes to
the cutting room floor it's not
happening
Duke cannon is committed to giving back
to the men and women serving our country
that's why a portion of their proceeds
go directly to support veterans causes
Duke cannon sells everything you need
nothing you don't
big-ass brick of soap that's modeled
after the rough cut brick style soap
used by GIS during the Korean War and
it's well it's a it's a it's a big-ass
brick of soap just exactly how it sounds
they've also got the best damn beard
wash which is the best day I'm beard
wash I what I like about it is that the
messaging is very straightforward it
tells you exactly what's going on here
and as men I think we appreciate that
just tell me what it is it's a okay
don't get some cute name for the soap
what is this
it's a big-ass Brita soap okay well
that's what I'm looking for so thank you
very much now when you're using duke
canons big ass brick of soap or premium
hair goods that give you the the news
anchor thick hair or beard wash or
whatever it is you know don't be
surprised if you if you feel yourself
this this sudden urge to sing the
national anthem or if maybe a bald eagle
swoops down to smell your luscious hair
it should be a little creepy but it's
been known to happen visit Duke Canon
right now and get 15% off your first
order with promo code Walsh that's a
visit that says Duke Cannon dot-com free
shipping on orders over $35 all right
the the Star Tribune the paper and
Minneapolis ran a story over the weekend
about representative Ilhan Omar here's
the lead of the story says new
investigative documents released by a
state agency have given fresh life to
lingering questions about the marital
history of Representative Ilhan Omar and
whether she wants married a man possibly
her own brother
to skirt immigration laws now that's not
an accusation that you hear every day
against politicians is it that's not one
that's that's that's that's a that's a
that's a new one the Star Tribune has
apparently been ignoring this story for
a long time for four years really months
or years they've been ignoring it
they're the local that's Minneapolis and
Johan Omar of course is representative
for Minnesota so they're sort of the
local crew there and during the campaign
they didn't talk about it didn't talk
about they're only coming out with it
now because they have no choice because
because of theirs the evidence is piling
up and they have to say something to
acknowledge it and I tell you that just
because there are some conservatives who
I saw over the weekend were seemed like
they were tempted to give the Star
Tribune some credit and say oh well this
is a liberal rag but yeah they've done
some real journalism here and give him
credit for that no don't get many credit
they they they only did it because they
absolutely had to when they tried not to
they don't want to they did because they
had to
is it true though that's really the
that's really the main point here that's
what matters is it true well I guess we
don't know right we don't
don't know exactly if it is or not it
would be a serious crime if it is true
and it would also be really creepy and
weird that you married her brother but
we can't say for sure there is a lot of
smoke and the thing is it's a very
peculiar peculiar I should say peculiar
it's a very peculiar type of smoke it's
it's oh it's a really weird smoke it's a
smoke that indicates that you married
your brother my point is that that's if
you didn't marry your brother why would
there be any smoke at all in that
direction you said I'm saying most of us
have never married our brothers right I
haven't married my brother you haven't
married yours not something most people
do and if you've never married your
brother there probably is not going to
be any reason for anyone to ever think
you did it's just it's not something
that will ever come up you're never
gonna have to deny it if you're in a
position where you have to deny that you
married your brother that probably means
at a minimum that something really weird
is happening right now there are some
accusations that politicians face all
the time there are the more kind of par
for the course accusations that almost
everyone faces or
politicians of a certain type or more
likely to face and in that case well
then you really have to look at it look
at the evidence maybe they did it maybe
they didn't you have to look at the
evidence here also but the very fact
that there is any evidence is itself a
piece of evidence pretty damning piece
of evidence that she did it although who
knows in its a claim that really is on
the surface seem so bizarre and
outlandish that a lot of even
conservatives myself included have sort
of ignored it up into this point because
we all just assumed it was some rumor
started on an internet forum somewhere
but apparently that's not the case
reading now from The Daily wire report
on this story says newly discovered
official documents released on Sunday
suggests that representative al Hungnam
Omar lived with her current husband
Ahmed here Z during the entire time that
she was legally married to Ahmed el me
the man that critic
allege is her brother the Washington
Examiner opposed reports that Omar tells
her marital history the following way
mm - Omar married here see in a faith
ceremony but never legally married 2008
Omar and heresee decided to end our
relationship in our faith tradition
early 2009 Omar legally married l me
2011 Omar and L me religiously divorced
2011 Omar and here C reconciled 2017
Omar and L me belatedly obtained their
legal divorce 2018 Omar and here C
legally married very confusing it's kind
of the worst soap opera ever it sounds
like the the report goes on Oh March
time light of events appears to conflict
with newly uncovered documents from the
Washington examiner's tiene lo who notes
that the evidence suggests that Omar has
always been in a marital relationship
with hears he even when she was married
to L me it goes into the public
documents that they found I'm not gonna
I'm tempted to read this entire report
I'm not gonna do that because it is very
complicated difficult to explain
I would Curt just go to Delhi wire comm
and look look it up and read for
yourself there's a lot of there are many
documents here that flesh all this out
that I'm not going to read the specifics
of but you could go and look at it for
yourself this all ties into you know
she's also she was the subject of a
campaign finance violation probe so
that's tied into this and so we've got
campaign finance violations potentially
we've got her defrauding the immigration
system potentially there's also another
crime potentially on the list here and
that would be perjury it I'm trying to
find at the very end of the article it
gets into Omar swore in court that she
has no contact with L me her alleged
brother and former husband apparently no
contact with them doesn't know where he
is doesn't know anyone in his family
can't get a hold of him that's what she
swore to the court but there's reason to
believe based on other documents that
that's not true either and that in fact
she lied even then so
this is this is all just crazy and
devastating for the Democrats which is
why they're ignoring it and it's why the
liberal media wants nothing to do with
this because not only is she a Democrat
of course and she's one of the fresh
faces of the Democrat Party and she's
kind of a rising star the Democratic
Party but for her to turn out that she
herself committed immigration fraud that
would be remarkable especially when this
is something that Republicans are
talking about all the time how you have
people defrauding our immigration system
Democrats are saying oh that's not
really a problem no one's doing that and
then one of your own people one of the
most visible a rising star the Democrat
Party herself is guilty of it
potentially allegedly well that's
devastating for them what's even though
what's even more devastating though I
think for me to think about is that as
bizarre as all this is and as horrible
as it would be if it's true I think it
will have no effect on her politically
because we know for one the media is not
gonna report it they're running cover
for her and so Democrats can always rely
on that that could always count on that
that the media's gonna cover for them
but so I think a lot of her constituents
a lot of voters will never hear about it
even if they did hear about it though in
fact even if Omar came out and admitted
and said yeah I married my brother what
of it
hey love is love or if she said or if
she said I think a better angle for her
be listen the immigration system is
unjust it's impossible to get through I
was you know I needed to come here for
the sake of my family my family needed
to come the United States and it was my
only option and so this is a this is
your this is America's fault this is the
fault of the the system for forcing me
as an immigrant woman to make this
difficult choice to marry my brother she
could
we go with that as she could admit it
and go with that angle and I think she
would get away with him because her
constituents don't they have no respect
for our immigration system they don't
care about it and that by her cuz I mean
when I say her can still I should say
not her constituents but specifically
her voters her supporters have no
respect for our immigration system they
don't care about it
they have no respect for the truth and
don't care about that so the fact that
she lied and committed fraud they don't
care about that either and so she could
easily get away with this and that
probably is the most depressing thing of
all even more depressing than someone
marrying their brother okay a couple of
other brief things both Twitter related
unfortunately Alexandria kzo Cortes
tweeted something over the weekend they
got 107 to 72 thousand likes and you'll
understand why I'm reading this in a
minute when you hear it because it's so
powerful and brave and insightful and
that's why hundred and seventy two
thousand people liked it she said I have
absolutely zero patience for completely
certified card-carrying flag-waving
racists none they can take their little
tiki torches somewhere else we don't
give them an inch a second a sliver of
sunlight nor the time of day and neither
should you
Wow so so brave I mean the courage the
courage it took to write this you know
to come out against racism to say I
don't like racism I'm against racism
I am anti racism racism I want no part
of it I just I can't fathom the courage
it takes for for someone to say this
because all the rest of us we're all
like oh racism I plead the fifth yeah I
don't want to talk about that I'm not
gonna tell you how I feel about racism
I'm a little too I don't want to get
into that subject that's what the rest
of us say right because we're so afraid
to take this bold stand of coming out
against racism
this woman is fearless my god she is she
is a firecracker isn't she and I
especially liked how she's
against completely certified racists so
if you've got your racist certification
and you're in your card you know your
little business card I'm a racist how
are you with your contact information
yeah because if you meet another racist
then you need to
oh you're racist too Oh which races do
you hate oh really me too what well
here's my business card
look me up sometime give me a call we'll
talk anyway so she's she's specifically
coming out against those people that
would the rate there god they're
certified
they're licensed and she's saying no
thanks you folks get out of my face
incredible courage all right and then we
have a reporter on Twitter
Olivia newsy nosey newsy relaying a
scene from a Planned Parenthood event
where some Democratic candidates showed
up to this Planned Parenthood event
speaking of courage really facing a
hostile audience there and they took
questions from people in the crowd at
this event and here's how she describes
it Olivia she says that at Planned
Parenthood event a non-binary activist
just asked Castro how he'll expand
sexual and reproductive health for trans
people Julian Castro Castro responds by
first asking which pronoun the activist
prefers they replied I actually don't
use any pronoun which receives some
applause now I love that sentence I
don't use any pronoun the whole
non-binary choose my own pronoun thing
is exposed for the joke that it is in
just that one said it's I don't use any
proto I don't use any pronouns oh I
actually don't like pronouns you see the
problem there yes you do use pronouns
because I is a pronoun so you do use
them of course you do you wouldn't be
able to communicate if you didn't at
least use a pronoun like I you need to
be able to refer to yourself as I or you
wouldn't be able to communicate just
like we need to be able to use words
like he and she in order to communicate
as well otherwise if we can't use a word
like he or she when referring to you
when talking about you to someone else
which is usually when the words he and
she come up if we're talking to you and
there probably isn't any reason to say
he or she but if we're talking about you
to someone else if we're relating some
information about you telling a story
about you we need to have a pronoun
because then otherwise we'd have to say
some we'd have it would be like so I saw
Bob today and Bob told me that when bob
was driving to the store two days ago
Bob got into a car accident and Bob
won't get Bob's car back from the shop
for a while you know etc it just becomes
utterly ridiculous and just completely
silly and nonsensical but this is what
we're expected to we're expected to
reduce ourselves to nonsense to
embarrass ourselves to jump through
hoops to reject the basic rules of
grammar to make idiots of ourselves to
make a mockery of everyday language
everyday communication all because
someone has decreed that they don't like
a certain pronoun oh no no that's I know
that pronoun is I don't like that
product also that verb and that adverb I
don't like those either don't use those
don't use those in my presence and
here's a list of 46 nouns you're know
along I said I don't like those oh and
here's some adjectives I don't like
either you see it doesn't you don't get
to do that you don't make the you don't
make grammatical rules and and even if
we're talking about you you can't say
well but certainly if you're talking
about me I can control what you say no
you can't you don't get to decide what
rules of grammar apply when we're
talking about you it doesn't work that
way I don't like those products well
okay great it's good for you you don't
like them fantastic
thanks for letting me know but we're not
bending the English language into some
distorted shape just to accommodate you
this again as I often point out is
is just arrogance there is so much in
this non-binary gender you know choose
your own gender all this stuff there's a
lot of you know there's a lot of
confusion people are very confused a lot
of self-loathing involved in it so
that's all there but then there's also a
ton of arrogance where people are what
they want to do is bend the rules of
grammar to suit them make everything a
million times harder for everybody else
so we've got to jump through all these
hoops and we don't know what to say and
we have to use you know come up with we
have to sound like like morons when
we're talking of what you're not using
any pronet oh just just making life
harder for everybody else just because
it would make you feel better
so along with the confusion the
self-loathing there's also a ton of
arrogance in it which is why I just have
I have very little patience for it and I
think sometimes the correct response to
that stuff is just to say you know what
kid over yourself really I don't use any
pronouns but oh man
okay now here's something that that I
let's see a couple other things I wanted
to talk about well let's let's talk
about this first I have to mention an
advice columnist eg Neral now alleges in
a new book which will be in stores tuned
soon that she was raped by Donald Trump
some 20 years ago they were both in
their 50s she says it happened in the
dressing room of a department store they
went in the dressing room together
consensually this is what she says Carol
says she went there because she wanted
to see Trump try on lingerie and then he
raped her she says and but she's not
gonna press charges because she also
says that the press charges would be
disrespectful of migrant women that's
what she said
I what's the connection why how would
that be disrespectful
it's so if you're raped and you press a
charge did just what but there's a lot
of that there's a lot of what in this
story there's a lot of things that just
don't make any sense you know that I'm
not one to reflexively defend Trump if I
thought he was guilty I would say so if
I thought there were some credibility to
these claims I would say so but I have a
hard time with this let's start with the
fact that she was raped by the now
president of the United States but said
nothing about it until she wrote it in a
book saving a rape accusation for a book
is just well it doesn't help your
credibility if this actually happened
wouldn't you just come out and say it
say it especially during the campaign
before he's president but you you write
it in a book and you use it to sell the
book that it's hard for me to believe
that an actual rape victim would make
that choice
let's let's hear Carole herself actually
described the scene here she is on CNN
talking about this accusation when we
walked into the lingerie department
there was nobody there
which was strange it was in the evening
so and on the counter were three really
fancy boxes and a see-through bodysuit
he walked right to the bodysuit and
snatched it up and say go put this on
now that struck me as so funny because
here I am 52 I am NOT gonna be put my
idea was I said no you put it on and he
said no it looks like it fits you I said
no it goes with your eyes so I am
spinning a comedy scene in my head
banter back and forth I get it but you
see how funny that would be to make him
put that on and you by the way used to
be a comedy writer on Saturday Night
Live you were engaging in this banter as
I think many of us would yes you didn't
know what violence no I had unfold and
you could never have known that and of
course although I thought it was pretty
stupid well I mean I understand that
afterwards in retrospect you blame
yourself many women in the
situation do okay so you notice how
Alison Cammarata the CNN anchor there is
literally coaching her through the
accusation she's framing it for the
accuser helping her to explain it she's
she's you know walking her through it
giving her answers for any questions
that might come up saying oh yeah that
says totally normal
I think she even said oh when when Carol
said that she wanted to go in the
dressing room so that Trump could try on
see-through lingerie and did Cammarata
said something like as anyone would or
something as anyone would really anyone
would ask Donald Trump to come into a
dressing room and try on see-through
lingerie I don't think anyone would do
that
ie I wouldn't if I met Donald Trump that
would probably not be something that I
would request I think most of us would
wouldn't do that so it's it's very
bizarre now I could believe that they
meet in this department store for
whatever reason Trump makes a
flirtatious flirtatious half-joking
comment about a try on this and then she
says why don't you try it on you know
and so I could believe that part and
scene right there right but then so she
actually goes into the dressing room
with him so that he could literally try
it on with her right there in the room
with him and she says oh it's all it's a
comedy see I've hatched a comedy scene
this will be hilarious
let's be whole hey guy hey guy I hate I
don't really don't know it all wouldn't
it be hilarious if you tried on this
lingerie in the dressing room I'll come
in with you get naked try it on to be
it'll be hilarious we'll have a great
laugh about it I may be but maybe that
happen I've hard time believing and it's
just really bizarre and so you have to
apply the principle of we don't know
what happened we'll never know sure for
sure now we have to look at the the
story
see the two possibilities one is that
she made this up the other is that it
actually happened and then it's simply a
matter of for us what's which one is
more plausible is it more plausible that
this woman randomly decided to go into a
dressing room with Donald Trump so he
could try a lingerie that he raped her
right there in the middle of a
department store and and then she ran
away she didn't tell anybody about it
publicly anyway until she wrote it in a
book so she could sell the book is that
plausible or is it more plausible that
she just made this up to sell a book or
a kind of an in-between option that she
really did have some kind of encounter
with Donald Trump
that was actually consensual that maybe
she then regretted or felt weird about
and then you know so there's also that
possible of all those possibilities
which is which is the least plausible it
seems to me right now
barring more evidence being produced
which I don't know what kind of evidence
could be produced the the least
plausible option is that it happened
exactly as she describes in my view all
right um let's we've also got Elizabeth
Warren now calling for gay reparations
for reparations for gay people not a
joke she really is calling for that and
but I think I'll save that for tomorrow
we'll talk about that tomorrow because I
think that deserves a closer inspection
all right we'll do some emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Brad says hey
Matt is there anything on this planet as
narcissistic as the modern-day bridal
shower please enlighten your audience
with a classic Matt Walsh rant well I
don't know if I have a classic Matt
Walsh rant for you I'm not sure what
that what constitutes a classic Matt
Walsh rant I will say that I think not
just the bridal shower but the whole
wedding scene has become of course that
I'm not the first person to point this
out of course but the whole wedding
scene has become
incredibly narcissistic and
self-centered and and and kind of absurd
and and I mean we all do it I I did it I
I had the classic traditional wedding
traditional by our standards today where
you spend more money than you probably
need to and it's a whole big production
and blah blah blah so we did it that's
what most people do but yeah but I think
it probably is I don't know I guess I
don't have much of a rant at all I'm
just I'm just sort of nodding my head in
agreement with you I think it is more
narcissistic and and and and more
involve the more expensive than it needs
to be and so there you go not much of
our hands sorry this is from Alison says
Matt huge fan of the show I'm wondering
what your thoughts are about the
situation in Indy so far three area
Catholic schools have been directly
impacted by LGBTQ issues and firings
related to them earlier this school year
ron's Sally High School think it's fired
a guidance counselor after she was outed
for being gay in the last two days two
other high schools both more prominent
in the Catholic community were pressured
by the archdiocese to fire LGBTQ members
Bree booth
why can't they just these just have
normal names that I can pronounce I
don't sound like a [ __ ]
Bree Bree booth Bree beau Jesuit
preparatory school decided not to fire
them was immediately excommunicated from
the Dartz diocese cat Cathedral High
School shockingly just days after made
the opposite decision I'm a 2010 alum of
Cathedral High School who is having a
ton of thoughts about this issue here is
cathedrals official explanation what she
links to it's so again my question to
you are these do you think this handling
of LGBTQ employees will continue at
Catholic institutions nationally do you
agree with cathedrals handling of the
situation thanks for your thoughts
whether it will be national it really
depends on the arch on the diocese do I
agree
what they're handling listen I don't
like to see anybody get fired but if
you're gonna work for a Catholic school
and this is something that Catholic
schools are upfront about at the at the
outset and in it and I don't know about
this is specifically the case here but
in many Catholic schools you have to
sign something swearing that you believe
in and will uphold Catholic teaching and
even if you don't have to sign something
if you do have to sign it then to me
it's clear-cut if you sign anything if
you at any point made it made any kind
of official oath to uphold Catholic
teaching and you were lying then of
course you should be fired and I don't
care what you were what the issue is
whether it's gay gay issue or anything
else you lied you you got hired under
false pretenses and so of course you
should be fired there but let's say that
you didn't have to you didn't really
have to sign anything but you're still
going to work at a Catholic High School
which the job of a Catholic high school
or a Catholic school of any grade is to
educate kids but also to instill
Catholic values and so that's your job
your job is partially at least and
substantially to help instill Catholic
values and an understanding of Catholic
teaching so you have to know that before
you get the job at the Catholic school
and if you get that job even though you
reject Catholic teaching then you're
just not suited for that position you
you it's not like you could go work and
it's not like Catholic schools are the
only option you go to public school you
go to a private school that's not
Catholic but the Catholic Church does
not hide the Catholic Church makes no
qualms about about its position on these
topics everybody knows so you know that
going in
that's why that's where I stand on that
so I fully support their decision to
fire them because it's not you know you
you clearly are you you've taken a jut
your job is to instill Catholic values
and Catholic teachings you clearly
aren't interested in doing that job you
don't want to do that job because you
don't agree with Catholic teaching which
fine you're free to not agree but just
why go work in a Catholic school of all
places of all the options why that it
doesn't make any sense to me so it's
hard for me to have sympathy for these
people even though I do if you lose your
job I have some sympathy but still why
of all your options why did you go there
you don't agree you obviously now think
about it the Catholic Church has always
taught that marriage is between a man
and a woman that's been the teaching for
2,000 years if you disagree then that
means that you do not respect or
acknowledge the authority of the
Catholic Church you think the Catholic
Church is wrong about a crucial moral
issue and if it is and it has been wrong
for 2,000 years
then the Catholic then you shouldn't
listen the Catholic Church at all about
anything you shouldn't be Catholic
you should why do you even want to work
at a Catholic school in that case that's
the point here if the Catholic Church is
wrong about the gate about the gay issue
which I don't think they are but if they
are then that means the Catholic Church
has been wrong about a crucial moral
issue theological issue for 2,000 years
which means that the entire credibility
of the Catholic Church is destroyed and
if that if it has no credibility if it's
wrong then again why and you which you
must think is the case if you disagree
with it on this issue then why would you
want anything to do with it
why would you want to teach at the
school I can only assume it's because
you have these negative thoughts about
the Catholic Church and Catholic
teaching and so you want to kind of
undermine it from the inside
that's your mission which I would have
to assume it is if you would still go
for the job then that's all the more
reason for the school to fire you
because your mission is the exact
opposite of the stated mission of the
school so that's where I stand on that
and I think we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed
today on the Ben Shapiro show the
Democrats get increasingly radical now
it's free college for everyone ever
that's today on the bench Shapiro show